So, the world that we live in continues
to exist in a constant state of change,
and my life is no exception
to that rule.
What I'm trying to say is that I moved out.
You guessed that already, didn't you.
Casa de Cherimon is dead and gone.
Me and Alex have had our housemate divorce now.
I managed to keep all of the kids,
which makes me very happy.
He's only going to see them on fortnights,
but they love him more, so.
Currently, I'm living
in house limbo.
I'm waiting to move into my
new flat, and while I do that,
I am staying here
with my girlfriend.
Ahh! He's got a girlfriend.
Yeah I do.
Did you seriously think
this was my new bed?
She's called Emily, the same
Emily that I mentioned last week.
We've been dating for about six months now,
it's been going very, very well,
and I appreciate you not making a big deal
out it, thank you very much.
There is something a little emasculating
about sleeping in this bed,
and what you can't see is the whole thing is
patterned with many, many tiny little flowers,
but I think the thing that all men have
to deal with at some point in their lives
is the fact that we do kind
of like pretty things.
There is no doubt in my mind that
I wouldn't feel comfortable
going into a store and buying pink
detergent that smelled like lilies,
but, at the same time, I'm not going
to be complaining about the fact
that I will be smelling delightful
for the next two months.
Now while I'm staying here, I've had to move
the majority my stuff into storage,
which meant hiring a
Man and Van Service,
also known as the
Feel Pathetic and Puny Service.
Ciaran was nice enough to come over that
day in the hopes that he would help me  move,
but we spent the majority
of the time just sitting there,
watching a much more capable human
doing all of the moving for us.
And the one time when we did offer to
help out, we tried to move a desk
through the doorway and through the hallway,
and the moving guy was very much like,
"You should probably take the legs off before
you do that. It'll make it much easier."
But we were like, "No, we can use our
superior intellects to maneuver this
door in a way that will get
us horrendously stuck.
Eventually, we just had to bring it back
and take the legs of, like he suggested,
because he knows best 'cause
he moves stuff for a living.
Not everything that I own did
make it out of that house.
There was some stuff that I was like,
"You know, I should throw this away,
but it's a little bit too big and maybe
a little bit too cool to do that,"
so, what I decided to do was
hide it in the attic.
So, when the next owner final
does decide to look up there,
they're going to have what I think
is a treasure trove of goodies.
They're going to find a couple of VCR players, an obnoxious
electronic Nerf Gun, and a unicycle.
Remember that unicycle?
Never learned how to rid that unicycle.
As a whole, the moving experience has
been a mixed bag to say the least.
It's mostly just been
horrendously stressful.
But absolutely nothing compares to the
experience of being the last person to leave the house
and shutting the door, knowing
that your keys are still inside.
It was like leaving a hotel room
and like worrying that you might have
left something in there
times a thousand.
It was so stressful, but it
also kind of invigorating.
I would kind of recommend
moving to anyone
just so you can have that experience
once in your life.
It's pretty great. So, yeah. I've moved, gonna be
in my new place in a couple of months time,
and I have decided, to myself, that
when I move into my new place
after I've settled in a little bit,
I'm gonna get a kitten
because Alex never really liked animals
and I'm gonna be living on my own
and I quite like a little companion.
So there you go. That's a change
you're excited about.
Exactly. See you later.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Okay, here's last week's video
in case you missed it.
It's all about how I made my
second short film, "Offline."
It also happens to be the last video
ever to be shot in Casa de Cherimon,
so, very important historical record that everyone
should see at least once in their lives.
I promise, you'll be telling your grandkids where
you were when you saw, "Making Offline."
Alright, bye.